creo que probablemente el concepto más
incomprendido de toda la ciencia y como
todos sabemos se está convirtiendo en
uno de los conceptos más discutidos tal
vez no en el ámbito científico pero sí
en la cultura popular es la idea de la
evolución evolución cada vez que
escuchamos esta palabra aún cuando no la
escuchemos en el contexto de la biología
nos imaginamos que algo está cambiando
está evolucionando así que cuando la
gente usa la palabra evolución en su
contexto cotidiano piensan que es esta
noción de cambio no soy muy buena
dibujando así que digamos que aquí está
un simio que se encuentra encorvado
todos hemos visto esta imagen en el
museo de historia natural el simio está
caminando con la espalda encorvada y
tiene su cabeza inclinada hacia abajo
con un poco de imaginación
este es el simio y luego nos muestran
esta imagen en la que el simio poco a
poco separa cada vez más erguido y
finalmente se convierte en un hombre que
va camino
felizmente hacen su trabajo y ahora él
está caminando completamente erguido y
se entiende de manera implícita que
caminar erguido es mejor que no caminar
erguido creo que todos hemos visto esto
si alguna vez has ido a un museo de
historia natural aquí hay más simios que
cada vez están más erguidos y finalmente
se llega a un ser humano y nos da esta
idea de que los simios de alguna manera
se convirtieron en seres humanos y he
visto esto en múltiples contextos en
clases de biología e incluso en la
comunidad científica donde se dice que
el simio evolucionó en ser humano o el
simio evolucionó en un pre humano que
sería el simio que se encuentra casi
erguido es decir el que estaba solo un
poco encorvado y se parecía un poco a un
simio y un poco a un ser humano y quiero
ser muy clara en esto a pesar de que
este proceso si ocurrió
si hay criaturas que con el tiempo han
acumulado cambios criaturas cuyos
antepasados se parecían a este al inicio
y luego se parecían más a este no hubo
un proceso activo en marcha como tal
llamado evolución no es que el simio
pensará me gustaría que mis hijos se
parecieran más a él así que de alguna
manera voy a hacer que mi adn cambie y
sea más como el de él tampoco es que el
adn supiera el adn no dijo es mejor
caminar erguido que estar encorvado por
lo que voy a tratar de alguna manera de
cambiar espontáneamente y convertirme en
el la evolución no es así por ejemplo
algunas personas pueden imaginar que
alguna vez hubo un árbol y en la parte
alta de ese árbol hay un montón de fruta
podrían ser manzanas y por acá hay algún
tipo de criatura parecida a un caballo y
dice me encantaría poder comer algunas
de esas manzanas y solo porque esta
criatura quiere alcanzar las manzanas
tal vez la próxima generación sigue
intentando estirar su cuello
luego generación tras generación los
cuellos de estas criaturas se vuelven
más y más largos y finalmente se
conviertan en jirafas eso no es
evolución y la evolución no implica esas
cosas aunque a veces la noción cotidiana
de la palabra evolución pareciera
hacernos pensar de esa manera lo que es
la evolución y de hecho este es el
término que yo prefiero usar es
selección natural
selección
natural
lo que significa literalmente es que en
cualquier población de organismos vivos
va a haber variación y esta es una
palabra clave variación solo significa
que hay diferencias entre individuos de
una misma especie si te fijas en los
niños que van a tu escuela
puedes encontrar variaciones algunos
niños son altos
algunos son bajos algunos tienen el pelo
rubio otros tienen el pelo negro
etcétera siempre hay variación y la
selección natural es este proceso en el
que los factores ambientales a veces
seleccionan ciertas variaciones algunas
variaciones pueden no ser importantes y
algunas variaciones son muy importantes
un ejemplo que se da en varios libros de
biología me parece que se llama
milanismo industrial y trata acerca de
las mariposas del abedul o polillas
moteadas que son estas polillas de color
blanco con manchas negras y ocurrió en
los tiempos previos a la revolución
industrial en inglaterra
voy a dibujar algunas polillas por aquí
aquí tenemos una polilla y colocaré dos
más por aquí
en la población de las polillas moteadas
solo había esta variación algunas de
ellas tenían más manchas negras que
otras algunas polillas podrían haberse
visto a sí blancas en su mayoría con un
poco de gris por aquí otras podrían
haberse visto así con algunas manchas
negras y algunas de ellas podrían haber
tenido muy pocas manchas blancas tienes
esta variación natural igual que en
cualquier población de animales donde
puedes encontrar alguna variación en los
colores ahora bien todas las polillas
estaban felices así probablemente
durante miles de años solamente con esta
variación natural esta variación fue una
característica sin importancia para
estas polillas pero luego ocurrió la
revolución industrial en inglaterra y de
todas las fábricas que utilizaban
máquinas de vapor alimentadas por carbón
se liberó una gran cantidad de hollín y
así de repente muchas de las cosas que
una vez fueron de color gris o blanco
por ejemplo algunos troncos de árboles
posiblemente había algunos árboles cuyos
troncos solían tener este aspecto y una
polilla moteada estaría bastante bien
con esto posiblemente también había
algunos troncos que eran bastante
obscuros pero de repente ocurrió la
revolución industrial y todo quedó
cubierto de hollín debido al carbón que
se quema en las fábricas y debido a esto
todos los árboles se vuelven negros o se
vuelven mucho más obscuros de lo que
eran antes todo esto implica un cambio
repentino e importante en el medio
ambiente de estas polillas y debes de
estar pensando que va a seleccionar a
estas polillas bueno algo que puedes
seleccionar a estas polillas son las
aves y la capacidad de estas aves para
ver a las polillas así que si el
ambiente de repentinamente se volvió
mucho más negro de lo que era antes
puedes adivinar lo que va a suceder
las aves van a ver a esta polilla con
mucha mayor facilidad de lo que van a
ver a esta otra polilla
ya que esta polilla al ser de color
negro y estar sobre un fondo negro va a
ser mucho más difícil de ver eso no
quiere decir que los pájaros no vayan a
ser capaces de atrapar a esta polilla
pueden atrapar a todas ellas pero ellos
van a atrapar a este tipo de polilla
blanca con mucha más frecuencia que a
las demás así que puedes imaginarte qué
sucederá a continuación si las aves
capturan a estas polillas antes de que
ellas puedan reproducirse o mientras se
están reproduciendo qué va a suceder
este tipo de polilla más obscura se va a
reproducir con mucha mayor frecuencia
que las polillas más blancas y entonces
vas a tener muchas más polillas que se
vean así vas a tener
y muchas más
bolillas negras
entonces qué pasó aquí hubo algún diseño
o hubo algún cambio activo por parte de
cualquiera de las polillas parecería
algo muy inteligente de hacer cambiar de
color del blanco al negro su entorno se
puso negro y esperaron un par de
generaciones y las polillas ahora son de
color negro y dices wow
estas polillas son genios todas ellas de
alguna manera decidieron convertirse en
polillas negras para ocultarse de las
aves con mayor facilidad pero eso no es
lo que sucedió había una gran variación
la población de las polillas moteadas y
lo que ocurrió fue que cuando su entorno
se volvió más obscuro estas polillas
blancas tuvieron muchas menos
oportunidades para reproducirse mientras
que estas polillas negras pudieron
reproducirse mucho más
estas polillas blancas fueron comidas
por las aves antes de que pudieran
reproducirse o mientras se reproducían
por lo que no podían producir tantas
crías por lo tanto esta característica
se convirtió en un rasgo dominante
y este tipo de polillas se convirtió en
una polilla negra y podrías estar
pensando que esto es sólo un ejemplo y
que necesitas más ya que estamos
hablando de la selección natural la cual
debería de aplicar para todo la
selección natural pretende explicar por
qué evolucionamos a partir de bacterias
o incluso a partir de rn auto replicante
de lo cual voy a hablar más en vídeos
futuros podrías pensar que necesitas más
pruebas de esto algo que puedas ver en
tiempo real y el mejor ejemplo de esto
es la gripe y voy a hacer otros vídeos
en el futuro que hablan acerca de lo que
son los virus y cómo se replican y los
virus son realmente fascinantes porque
en realidad no se sabe bien si están
vivos o no son literalmente pequeñas
cápsulas que contienen adn y a veces a
rn que más adelante aprenderemos que es
información genética la cual está dentro
de estos recipientes hechos de proteínas
que tienen estas formas geométricas y
eso
es todo lo que son no son como los
organismos vivos normales que se mueven
activamente y que tienen un metabolismo
activo y todo eso lo que hacen los virus
es que toman un poco del adn que tienen
y se lo inyectan a otras cosas que lo
pueden procesar y luego utilizan ese adn
procesado para producir más virus
podríamos hacer toda una serie de vídeos
acerca de los virus y la gripe es un
virus y lo que sucede todos los años es
que tienes un cierto tipo de virus que
tiene una cierta variación voy a marcar
la variación por cuántos puntos tienen y
vamos a decir que es una gripe humana
que infecta a los humanos y poco a poco
nuestro sistema inmunológico acerca del
cual también podríamos hacer toda una
serie de vídeos comienza a reconocer a
los virus y es capaz de atacarlos antes
de que puedan hacer mucho daño así que
ahora te puedes imaginar lo que sucede a
continuación digamos que esto de la
gripe actual todos tienen estos dos
puntos y hablaremos en el futuro acerca
de lo que son estos puntos y cómo pueden
ser reconocidos pero digamos que es por
medio de estos puntos que nuestro
sistema inmune los reconocen y empiezan
a saber que cada vez que se encuentran
con estas cosas verdes con dos puntos no
es algo bueno
así que los van a atacar de alguna
manera y destruirlos antes de que
infectan al sistema inmunológico y al
adn y a todo lo demás y de este modo
tienes una muy buena selección natural
una vez que el sistema inmunológico
aprender lo que es este virus y vamos a
hablar más adelante sobre lo que
aprender implica para un sistema
inmunológico van a empezar a atacar a
estos virus pero la gripe puedes pensar
que es muy astuta pero en realidad no lo
es porque no está consciente pero lo que
hace es que cambia constantemente así
que en cualquier población de la gripe
siempre hay un poco de cambio puede ser
que la mayoría de ellos tengan estos dos
puntos pero puede ser que de vez en
cuando uno de ellos tenga un punto otro
de ellos tenga tres puntos y puede ser
que sea una mutación al azar puede ser
que por cada millón de estos virus solo
uno tenga este único punto en vez de dos
puntos
pero qué va a suceder una vez que el
sistema inmune humano se acostumbre a
atacar al virus que tiene dos puntos
rojos cuando eso ocurra este virus no va
a tener que competir con los otros virus
para infectar a la gente va a tener el
adn de la persona infectada para sí
mismo este virus entonces va a ser más
exitoso de modo que para la temporada de
gripe del año que viene cuando la gente
empiece a estornudar y difunda este
virus en las manijas de las puertas y en
todos lados este virus va a ser el nuevo
virus de la gripe así que cuando vemos
este proceso en el que todos los años
hay un nuevo virus de la gripe eso es la
evolución y la selección natural
actuando en tiempo real está sucediendo
no es esta cosa que solo ocurre a lo
largo de miles de millones de años aun
cuando la mayoría de las cosas
importantes que vemos en nuestras vidas
e incluso a nosotros mismos están
basadas en estas cosas que ocurrieron a
lo largo de miles de millones de años
esto también ocurre cada año
otro ejemplo es si pensamos en los
antibióticos y las bacterias las
bacterias son estas pequeñas células que
se mueven alrededor y vamos a hablar más
sobre ellas en el futuro definitivamente
son seres vivos tienen metabolismo y
todo lo demás y sólo como una nota al
margen cuando la gente habla acerca de
las infecciones podrían estar hablando
de una infección viral que ocurre cuando
estos virus afectan tu adn y luego
utilizan tus mecanismos celulares para
reproducirse o podrían estar hablando de
una infección bacteriana en la que
participan estas pequeñas células que se
mueven por tu cuerpo y liberan toxinas
que hacen que te enfermes los
antibióticos matan a las bacterias los
antibióticos atacan a las bacterias
probablemente si conoces a algún médico
y le dices estoy enfermo creo que tengo
una infección bacteriana
dame algunos antibióticos un médico
responsable te debería de decir no voy a
darte antibióticos así como así porque
lo que corre es que cuanto más
antibióticos se utilizan
es más probable crear versiones o mejor
dicho es muy probable que ayudes a
seleccionar las bacterias resistentes a
los antibióticos y cómo funciona eso
digamos que todas estas son bacterias y
tienes varios millones de ellas y de vez
en cuando hay una que es un poco
diferente ahora en una población al azar
de bacterias todas estas serán enfermar
por igual y esta es sólo una diferencia
al azar en las bacterias puede ser que
en su adn ocurrieron algunos cambios
ligeros pero independientemente de eso
todas estas son el tipo de bacterias de
las que no deseas tener una gran
cantidad de ellas en tu sistema tu
sistema inmunológico las puede atacar
pero si tienes una gran cantidad de
ellas te podrían matar o hacer que te
enfermes ahora bien si todo el mundo
empieza a usar antibióticos cuando no
están enfermos o cuando en realidad no
los necesitan es posible que tengas un
antibiótico que es muy bueno para matar
a las bacterias verdes
pero qué pasa si de pronto matas a un
montón de las bacterias verdes bueno
ahora las bacterias azules tienen todo
el ecosistema para ellas solas antes
competían con todas estas bacterias
verdes para conseguir alimentarse de tu
cuerpo pero ahora la bacteria azul se
encuentra sola y ahora se puede replicar
sin problema y una vez más no es como si
hubiera ocurrido un proceso inteligente
aquí en el que una de las bacterias
dijeran voy a ser más inteligente que
las demás y me cambiaré a mí misma de
manera que pueda resistir los
antibióticos no esto solo son cambios
que ocurrieron al azar las mutaciones en
los virus y en las bacterias se producen
con frecuencia y estos cambios se
producen al azar esto podría ser un
cambio en mil millones pero si comienzas
a matar a toda la población de bacterias
que está compitiendo con esta bacteria
entonces ella puede comenzar a
reproducirse muy rápidamente y luego se
convierte en el tipo de bacteria
dominante y después el antibiótico que
había sido desarrollado con mucho
cuidado para
a las bacterias verdes es inútil y ahora
tienes esta superbacteria es posible que
hayas escuchado la palabra superbacteria
antes esto es una superbacteria no es
que se haya diseñado a sí misma de
alguna manera simplemente nos deshicimos
de su competencia y esto le permitió
asumir el control y no la podemos matar
porque todos los medicamentos sólo
servían en contra de su competencia y
estas bacterias continúan mutando y
mutando y si seguimos usando estos
antibióticos siempre estaremos
seleccionando las bacterias que no se
verán afectadas por los antibióticos en
fin creo que he hablado suficiente
acerca de esto pero este es un tema
super fascinante y realmente quería que
este fuera el primer vídeo de biología
porque la biología es el estudio de la
vida y podemos hablar acerca de cómo es
la vida y acerca de si los virus son
seres vivos o no pero si realmente
quieres estudiar a los sistemas vivos no
se puede hacer ninguna suposición que no
sea la selección natural
vamos ir a otro planeta donde las
criaturas no tengan adn o quizás tengan
algún otro tipo de información genética
almacenada en sus células o se
reproducen de alguna otra manera o ni
siquiera son formas de vida basadas en
el carbono tal vez estén basadas en el
silicio y si fuéramos a ese planeta con
el fin de estudiar la biología de ese
lugar todo lo demás que sabemos sobre la
biología y los virus y sobre el adn
sería inútil pero si entendemos este
concepto el concepto de la selección
natural que nos dice que el entorno
seleccionará y no es un proceso activo
son solo cosas que ocurrieron al azar
que escogen al azar cambios aleatorios y
que a lo largo de grandes periodos de
tiempo y estoy hablando de inimaginable
mente grandes periodos de tiempo esos
cambios se acumulan y podrían acumularse
hasta que ocurren cosas muy importantes
hablaremos más sobre esto en otro vídeo